[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRIS KLEBAN: Hello, everybody.
Hello, everybody.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
CHRIS KLEBAN: Great.
My name is Chris Kleban.
And together with Justin
Lawyer, we are product managers
on Google Cloud, and
we'll be talking to you
about machine learning on GCP.
So I'm a very
transparent person,
and I'm going to make
it very clear what
I hope your takeaways
are from this talk.
One, I want you to be really
excited about what you
could do with machine learning.
Two, I want you
to feel confident
that your organization can
successfully implement machine
learning with Google Cloud.
And three, I want you to trust
that with Google AI's focus
that we are the right platform
and partner for your ML
workloads.
Three takeaways,
and this is what
we're going to be talking about
for you to get those takeaways.
Before we dig into it, I
just want to say thank you.
We all have limited time
with our busy lives.
You've chosen to come to Google
Cloud, our Next conference,
and this session.
So thank you.
So what can ML do for you?
It could do a lot
of amazing things.
If your organization
has any competition,
I guarantee they're
looking at ML.
Now, ML is not necessarily
for inventing the insane.
If you're in
transportation, it's
not about how are we going
to create teleportation.
It's about taking your existing
businesses and processes
and being able to
re-imagine and reinvent
what you're doing today.
There's three kind
of big areas that ML
could help with that could
help you get insights,
or your customers, that could
help you innovate your products
and help with automation.
Let's look at
automation real quick.
Self-driving trucks and cars--
taking the businesses
that everyone
is doing today with
transportation and cabs
and making it faster, and
cheaper, and easier, and safer.
Let's look at innovation--
one of our customers,
Disney, uses our product
AutoML to innovate
their retail service.
They wanted their
user experience
to be really quick to find the
product they're looking for.
So they used a web interface
to create a custom model,
no ML expertise needed.
And now in their
search experience,
you could type "Mickey
Mouse on the beach",
and it finds all the
products related to the beach
and Mickey Mouse--
really cool, really easy.
And insights-- let's
say you're a plane
manufacturer, an airline, and
you really care about safety.
Thanks to IoT,
there's tons of data
that these
instruments are doing.
And what if you collect that
data, what if you process it?
And what if you could
predict that maybe there's
a part on the plane that
needs maintenance before it's
regularly scheduled?
Insights for safety, so
feel excited about what
your organization can do.
So a show of hands--
who here, their
organization, is looking
into machine learning today?
Great.
One more show of hands--
who here thinks they understand
what machine learning is?
OK, about half of you.
Last question-- who knows what
a machine learning model is?
OK, most of you.
So I'll just touch over
this really briefly.
Machine learning is about data,
and taking data, and getting
insights and action.
There's all kinds
of data out there--
images, unstructured text,
relational databases,
sequence information.
And what machine learning
is is taking that data,
taking an ML algorithm
of various sorts,
and passing through that
data through that algorithm
with a huge set
of infrastructure.
And as you pass
that data through,
the machine learning
model is created.
And this model gets
better and better.
The more data, the
better algorithms,
the more infrastructure.
And you use that model to
create insights, automation,
and innovation.
So we all know this
service, web search.
Google's been an AI
company and a data company
for 18 years now,
collecting the world's data,
making it accessible
and usable by all.
And we have a lot of
expertise in this area--
large scale data centers,
AI experts, data experts.
And what Google Cloud is is
about bringing that expertise
to you with ML.
This is a nice little story
about how we, internally, have
implemented ML successfully.
Our internal AI team called
Brain, they create ML models--
take a bunch of data,
through an algorithm,
pass it through a huge
scale of infrastructure,
and create ML models.
But not every single
software developer at Google
is an ML expert.
So what we've done is, we
went around to our software
developers and
trained them, here's
how you can implement ML
with these existing models.
So what this graph is showing
is the number of source code
repositories that our developers
are using the Brain's ML model
to implement successfully
AI into internal services,
external products.
And we're bringing these types
of concepts to Google Cloud.
On the right, you'll see
a bunch of products that
have integrated and ML and AI.
I'm not going to talk about all
of them, I'll talk about two
of my favorites.
So I'm a father,
I have three kids.
And I take a lot of
digital photos of my kids,
a ridiculous amount,
maybe 100,000 in total.
And I had this Mac, and
I had some hard drives,
and I was worried about
storage, so I got Google Photos,
free unlimited storage.
Well, that's great.
It's cheap, it's
scalable, I don't
got to worry about
backing things up.
But really, the innovation
was the search feature.
It has facial recognition
and knows who my kids are.
I can click on a
picture of my face
in my phone, type in a word
like a beach or a boat,
and now it goes
through 100,000 photos
and finds the exact
photo I'm looking for.
In the past, that would have
taken me 20 minutes to find.
ML is innovating,
and so could you.
So no matter what size your
organization is, no matter what
type of technical staff, there's
different ways to implement ML.
And we're going to be
talking about both ways.
The first way is to
use our ML models.
You don't need to
be an ML expert,
you just need to be
a software developer
or your organization does--
any programming language with
the REST API, simple to use.
If you're a CXO out there or
an executive trying to decide,
do I fund the project?
It's very low risk to
take a high quality model,
have a software
developer use an API,
and implement it, get
started really quickly.
And the other route is
to build a custom model.
Maybe you're a domain
expert in your space
or you have access to
the data, and you want
to create your own ML model.
So we have a bunch of tools for
experts, a bunch of hardware
to get you fast and
cheap ML processing.
And this is where I'm going
to hand it off to Justin,
and he's going to talk
about these in little bit
more detail.
JUSTIN LAWYER: Thanks, Chris.
So thanks very much for coming.
Today, we're going
to talk about,
how do you find the
right tools for your job
as an expert in your field?
So first of all, as
Chris was mentioning,
Google has created a lot
of machine learning models
for specific applications to
power Google applications.
And so we then have wrapped
REST APIs around these for you
to consume.
We call these the
perception APIs,
because they're typically
around human perception
and how the user interacts
with the application.
So quickly going on to
the next slide here,
there are three main
categories of these APIs.
One is regarding site, the
other is around conversation,
and the third one
is around language.
I think it's important to maybe
walk through each of these
really quickly so you can kind
of understand out-of-the-box
capabilities that you can get
without you doing any coding
other than using a REST
API, and then implement that
into your application.
So first of all, for sight,
say you've got an image,
and you want to understand
what's in that image
automatically.
You pass that image
to the Vision API,
and you can understand what the
objects are within that image
automatically, and you can
figure out where the faces are,
and it can tell
different people.
For the Video Understanding
API, you can pass it the video,
and it can tell scene
transitions, different objects
within that video.
You can basically
search and find
what you're looking for within
the video or across videos
if you're passing
multiple videos.
OCR-- often, people have
documents that they've scanned.
And you need to kind
of understand what
the heck is in that document.
Maybe it's a PDF, maybe
it's a GIF, whatever
it is, you need to be able to--
not a GIF, a JPEG--
you might pass it into the API.
And then, it will
automatically detect
what are the words
in that document,
and give you that
raw text afterwards.
Or maybe you've got
an image of a scene,
and there are signs on the wall.
It'll give you the text
of what's on that sign.
So the OCR is really, really
handy in everyday applications.
The adult content one
is actually one really,
really important,
because you might
get user-submitted content.
You don't know
what's in that image.
You need to make
sure that you're not
presenting an inappropriate
image to your users.
So the adult content
detection is a really easy way
for you to detect what's
going on in that image,
and is that something
that you should filter out
for your users?
For the Conversation
class of APIs--
the audio to text-- you
might have a streaming audio
file that you then need to
figure out what is being said.
It will then transcribe that
event and give it to you.
It's useful for videos, for
real conversations with people,
for TV shows,
whatever it might be.
The reverse is also possible.
You might have a
text string that you
need to read out to your user.
Well, you pass the string
to the application.
And it will then create
the synthetic voice
that you can then
read off to your user.
Chat bots is a way for you
to engage with your users
and program the interactions
you would like in chat directly
with your user, and program
certain kinds of conversations
to go on, and help them
with customer service calls
or things like that.
From the Language
APIs, one of the things
that's really hard if if
you've got free-form text,
what the heck is
it really saying?
We will map out and figure
out the context of what
it's saying, map out the data
structure of the sentences,
give you the parts of speech
so you can figure out, OK,
what are the nouns,
what are the verbs, what
are the relationships of these?
And then, you can do
something intelligent
with that structure.
Sentiment analysis is
a situation where--
what's the mood that's
being transmitted along
with those words?
What we've had is-- we've seen
a lot of good success trying
to monitor, for instance, the
sentiment of customer service
emails or chats, and when
things are getting out
of hand, being able to
escalate that to the managers
so you can kind of make
sure things don't spiral out
of control.
Or if you need to understand
if something's aggressive,
or calm, or happy, how do you
make sure you're categorizing
things appropriately if you're
like ratings up customer
service calls, things like that?
In translation, it's a great way
to just automatically translate
from one language to the other.
And we'll talk a little bit
about that next as an example.
So for instance, say you
are a game developer,
and you have an
online community,
but they're coming from
all over the world,
speaking different languages.
You want them to be able
to talk to each other.
In real-time chat,
you can basically
have the ability to translate
to any of the other languages.
So the Translate API
makes that really easy.
Or you might be able to get
inbound customer service
emails, and be able to
translate that to a language
that your customer service
rep understands so that they
can then find the right article
to respond to your customer.
The nice thing about these
APIs is they're basically
just REST APIs.
Basically, we give
you a snippet of code,
you pop it into your app.
The only thing you
really have to change
is the key and the URI
to point to your data.
And voila, off you go.
It can't really get
any simpler than that.
The next question that comes
up is, what about performance?
How well do these actually work?
They work really great
for common use cases.
For some cases, you
might have a problem
that Google's never
had to deal with
or you might have to
deal with a situation
with a lot more detail than
Google has to deal with.
For instance, Google
would probably
tell the difference between a
bolt and a nail really easily.
But let's say you're
a manufacturer,
and you've got 2,000 different
bolts on your production line.
How do you tell the difference
between these for your parts?
Well, what we have
enabled is Cloud AutoML
so that you can provide images
of all of your parts labeled.
And we may not be able
to distinguish them
unless you give the labels.
We then train a model for you.
Then you get REST API
endpoint that you can then
use in your application.
So the nice thing about that
is it's really easy to use.
And you don't have to
know machine learning,
we do it for you.
But then, you can use
it in your application.
So the next question is,
well, how well does this work?
It actually works better
than all the open source
models out there.
And so you get a great
performing model.
And it's really easy to use.
So it's been really helpful.
So that's actually one
category of way to use ML.
Another way is let's say
I've got data scientists,
and I want to build my own model
because I've got my own data
and it's a custom problem
that I need to deal with.
Well, there's two
different ways to do this.
One is using the Cloud
managed services.
And these are services
where you don't
want to deal with
the infrastructure,
we'll deal with that for you.
That way, you can focus on your
machine learning processes.
So we've got
Dataproc and Dataflow
so you can deal with
your pre-processing.
Dataproc is essentially
Hadoop and Spark, but managed,
or Dataflow is using
Beam in the back end.
From a machine learning
processing perspective,
ML Engine, or Machine
Learning Engine,
allows you to automatically
spin up the infrastructure,
and we'll get to
that in a little bit,
and then tear it down
when you're done.
So it takes the
infrastructure pain away
from the data scientists.
It supports all
the top frameworks.
And we've got Datalab, which
is a managed notebook which
allows you to make the
data exploration easier.
So first about Datalab,
how many of you
out there have actually
used Jupyter Notebook
or know about Jupyter Notebooks?
So probably about a third
of you or half, so just
for the rest of
you so understand
what Jupyter Notebook
is-- it's essentially
an app where you can
point it to your data
and supply some code to be
able to analyze your data,
visualize that data, push
return, see it immediately, get
some feedback, and then iterate
on that, and keep iterating,
keep adding to it.
You can replay the
entire Notebook,
you can just play
certain snippets of that,
you can share with
your coworkers.
So it's a really great way
to explore, and visualize,
and prototype.
So it's a fantastic tool.
The nice thing about
Datalab is it's
pre-configured to connect to
all the different Cloud services
like BigQuery, and
ML Engine, et cetera.
So it's really easy to
just work off of the cloud.
You can also use it
locally on your laptop.
Machine Learning Engine
is really a great way
to do distributed learning
on any arbitrary data sites
for your data using
all the top frameworks.
And again, it's a
managed service.
So you just point it at
your model and your data,
and you just spin it up.
It takes care of all the
distributed training for you.
You don't have to worry
about it, terminates,
tears everything down, and so
you only pay for what you use.
So it's a really
efficient way to do this.
You don't have to worry about
accidentally leaving that VM on
and getting charged for
a month's worth of notice
when you get the bill.
The other nice
thing about this is
it also does batch prediction
and online predictions.
So basically, you can spin up
these batch prediction jobs
really efficiently.
Or for online prediction, it'll
create the REST API endpoint
for you for your model and
serve to whatever volumes
you need for any number
of apps that you've got.
So it's a great way to manage
your apps in a really easy way.
The other thing is, we found
that data scientists often
don't do optimization
of their models
because it's kind of a pain.
You have to vary all
the different parameters
and find the right
configuration for your data set.
Well, we've built
that into ML Engine
so it actually makes it
really simple for you.
You just give the
parameters, and it will then
go find the optimal model.
So instead of finding
just a good enough model,
you're actually finding the
best one for your data set.
So it really improves your
performance of your models.
So putting it all together
from a managed perspective,
we've got different services
for every step of the entire ML
lifecycle that you might have
to deal with for an application.
We've got the ingestion side,
the pre-processing side,
storage, and the exploring
and experimentation,
the visualization side, training
and serving your models,
or to be able to create
reports using Data Studio--
all of it on our
managed service,
you don't have to deal
with the infrastructure.
You don't have to have an SRE
managing all of those pagers.
The other way to do this
is doing it all yourself
and rolling your own solution.
There's actually some
very valid reasons
why some customers
would want to do this.
You might be a
researcher and you
want to be able to make changes
to any part of the stack you
want, it might be that you've
got a very custom pipeline,
or it could be that
you want cutting edge
open source software to plunk
in at any point you want.
There's lots of
different reasons
you might want to do that.
That's completely OK,
we love users like that.
You might also have a
hybrid implementation
where some stuff is on the
cloud and some stuff is on-prem.
That's a very common use case.
We want to support that.
So doing it yourself and
having a way to deploy that
is really important.
So the exact same
infrastructure that we
had before, which is managed,
the same kinds of open source
platforms are available for
you to roll automatically
on your own infrastructure.
You manage it.
And you get the exact
same hardware that's
powering the other solutions.
So we also make it
really easy to get
started with deep learning.
Deep learning has
really even taking off
as a really great way to find
the insights in complex data
sets.
And we provide a VM image that's
been certified and optimized
to work on GCE.
So out of the box, you
get a Jupyter Notebook,
you get access to
all the hardware
that Chris is going to
talk about in a moment.
And it's configured to get
you the best results possible.
So with one click,
you can deploy this
onto the machine of your
choice, getting access
to any accelerators that
you want, and off you go.
It's instant, ready to go.
We mentioned about
the commitment
that Google has to the
open source community.
Kubeflow is an open source
project that I love.
It started last fall as
a way to, on Kubernetes,
be able to create microservices
for specific ML jobs
like distributed
training or distributed
serving of different kinds
of models anywhere you want,
whether it's on GCP or on-prem.
So this is a highly portable
way to deploy these containers
everywhere you want.
And that way, your
deployments are
consistent from GCP
or on-prem, and you
don't have to worry about
the resource matching,
because Kubernetes
takes care of that.
It's a Kubernetes native
way of handling all of that.
And again, it's configured
to work on CPU, GPU, and TPU
on GCE.
On-prem, you get access to
whatever you have internally.
So how that might look if you
deploy that on GCE would be--
you would create
your GKE cluster,
which is a managed
Kubernetes cluster on GCP.
You would then be able to spin
up your JupyterHub notebooks,
spin up your TensorFlow training
service or any other framework
you wanted to put, and
then do the same thing
for your TensorFlow serving.
It would all have access
to your shared storage
on GCP, natural to Kubernetes.
So it's a great
way to actually do
this in a very portable manner.
That entire container can then
be deployed anywhere you want,
and it's a fantastic solution.
So now, I'm going
to pass the time
on to Chris is going
to talk about hardware.
CHRIS KLEBAN: Thank you, Justin.
So going back to the takeaways,
being excited about ML,
feeling confident that you can
implement ML on Google Cloud,
and Google's AI focus makes us
the right partner for your ML
workloads.
Let's talk about
that really quickly,
just to reiterate
some of these things.
If you're a developer and
you want to implement ML,
you don't need to be an ML
expert, use our API models,
get started right
away, low risk.
If those pre-trained ML
models aren't to your liking
or you need to do
something custom,
use a web browser with AutoML
to create custom ML models.
It's amazing, super simple.
And if you are data expert, or
a machine learning scientist,
or a domain expert, we have the
great tools for your workloads
as well.
You can successfully
implement ML on Google Cloud.
But let's talk about compute
and infrastructure briefly
and how it relates to ML.
80% of the recent AI
improvements and advances
have been attributed to more
available compute power.
But at a recent
TensorFlow event,
a survey has found that
people admit not having access
to enough compute for
their ML research.
That's a clear problem.
So let's go back a few
decades, because all of us
in this room working
on ML we're standing
on the shoulders of giants.
Neural networks and this
concept of how ML works,
it's decades old.
Taking a look at
the human brain,
and how neurons are
connected to each other,
and how they're
passing information
from one neuron to another,
it's an old concept.
But it's the recent
implementation
of large scale data centers
and hardware accelerators that
have enabled us to make
these big neural networks
and advances in ML.
So the infrastructure matters.
And why it matters is, no
matter which path you take--
building custom models,
using Google ML models--
it's that infrastructure
that's holding it up.
In our models, we've
already taken the data,
passed it through
great algorithms,
and passed it through this
infrastructure, large scale,
football-sized field data
centers over and over again
to make these models
better and better.
And we're going to
to keep doing that.
And with the Google Cloud,
we're giving you access
to that same scale, that same
power to do it yourself and do
it affordably.
One of our new ML
customers on GCP
is OpenAI, and talk
about large scale.
They went the unmanaged route.
They're a domain expert,
they're an AI thought leader,
and they're a
nonprofit organization
working on innovating with AI,
and making it open and safe.
They use 100,000
and more processors
to do reinforcement learning.
They're using thousands of
GPUs to do machine learning.
It's that access to scale that
is enabling them to innovate,
and it's Google Cloud that's
providing it for them.
Hardware accelerators
are so important,
and just hardware innovation.
With CPUs, we have Skylake.
But for ML workloads,
for distributed training
and large training jobs, we
need paralyzed compute power.
So we have, historically,
since February 2017,
we've launched three NVIDIA GPU
models, the K80, P100, V100,
it's high performance,
pass-through PCI.
With the V100, we have
NVLink interconnections,
super great for ML workloads.
The one thing that we make
a little different than some
of our competitors is
how we offer custom VMs.
Take any amount of CPU, any
amount of memory, whatever
GPU type you have, any
number of GPUs, create a VM,
use network-attached storage,
or if you want fast disk
I/O for a certain workload,
attach in-server SSD,
and just pay for what you want.
Or if you have a bottleneck,
adjust one of those.
Some of our other competitors
don't offer that flexibility.
And so you're going
to save money,
and your ML jobs are
going to go faster.
Actually going back one--
this week, we also launched
the P4 GPU, brand new,
it's coming out in a week.
It's great for ML
inference workloads.
So we're going to keep working
with our partner NVIDIA
to launch new GPUs.
So we don't just stop there.
AI focus in Google,
we have the TPU line.
We made Cloud v2 TPU,
available last year.
It's an ASIC purposely
built for machine learning.
And today, we've some new
announcements-- v3 coming out,
faster, cheaper ML workloads.
There's the TPU Pod,
which is a series of TPUs
connected with a fast network.
So again, Google's AI focus
is building infrastructure.
We're training these
ML models quicker,
and we're also
offering it to you.
You should trust that we're
the right partner for your ML
workloads.
Savings is a lot of money--
a big, big deal for
a lot of companies.
There's an assistant professor
in Stanford who has a budget,
and does some research in ML.
And he has a fixed--
you know, only so
much he could do.
So there's a win-win product
of the unmanaged route--
preemptible VMs, and
preemptible GPUs and TPUs.
Sometimes, we have
some spare capacity.
And ML batch workloads like
training and inference,
we offer 70% off GPUs and TPUs,
and announced this morning
we lowered the prices of TPUs.
So now, this researcher
could use our spare capacity,
get some savings,
run a batch workload.
It's not for all use
cases, because the capacity
isn't guaranteed.
It's not always there.
But if you're
researching and you
do some work or a big
organization that just needs
batch workloads once
in a while, that's
a great way to do more
innovation with less money.
Data is really
important with ML.
Google has a great fiber
network, great internet
connections.
So if you're moving your
data large chunks in,
we have it handled.
If you have a large, real-time
incoming flow of data through
various sources--
we have Cloud locations
all over the world.
If you need to
ship us some data,
we have an appliance we can
get you to ship large amount.
It's not just compute, it's
not just the great AI services.
It's the network,
it's the security,
it's everything built in there.
So we talked about a
lot of AI services.
We gave you an
overview and an intro.
We talked about how ML is not
about inventing the impossible.
It's about reimagining
and reinventing
what you're doing today.
There's over 14,000 customers
doing ML on GCP today.
So with our focus
on open, and hybrid,
and multi-cloud workloads,
our focus on hardware,
our new services that
we're announcing,
and the keynotes you
mentioned, new AutoML services,
high quality APIs--
it doesn't matter how
you want to do it,
you should feel excited
that you can do it.
You should feel confident that
you can successfully do it.
And Google is the
right partner for you.
There's a bunch of ways you can
learn more, get started, get
built. One I'll call out
specifically that I personally
used was Kaggle.
Kaggle is an ML competition
service and community.
When I was learning
ML, I joined,
didn't know what I was doing.
And there was an image
recognition competition
where drivers were either
paying attention to the road
or feeling distracted.
So I joined the community,
I joined the ML challenge.
They had a lot of resources
about how to use TensorFlow
and how to preprocess the data.
And Google is using Kaggle to
help the people in the world
learn ML.
And you too could use it.
Or if you're an organization
with a a bunch of data set,
you could start a competition
and have the world's ML experts
do ML for you.
There's a bunch of
resources on how
to learn about these services.
There's free credits if you're
not a Google Cloud customer
already.
So with that, we
wanted to thank you.
Our time is almost up.
We're going to do
some Q&A, so there's
two mics on either side.
And just ask some
questions, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]